the easiest way to make the thing that
you have more desirable is by limiting
your supply and let me explain so if you
have a service business or you sell
anything you probably have a cap on how
many people you could fill in any given
week or any given day and so rather than
just let it that be some invisible thing
that only you know communicate it
directly to the prospector and say hey I
can only take on three customers a week
and when you say that you inherently
limit the supply of your services and
whenever you limit something people want
it more and so make sure that you
communicate your own capacity
limitations in a way to actually make
your products and services more
persuasive and get more people to want
to buy